[Music]
what does that feel like when it's like
okay you're the front-runner people
expect you to like what is that like
it's incredibly surprising first of all
if it I mean we got Hannibal Lecter
Keyser Soze amongst a host of other
folks up in this joint so the fact that
I'm the front-runner brother from st.
Louis MO is it's sort of crazy so
humbled and like honestly I feel there's
so much build-up to everything like I'll
be happy when Sunday win lose or draw
has come to a complete and then the show
premieres and then we just go to work
I'm happy to go to work I walk out of
here in triumph I came I saw I conquered
my you have a conversation about it
because you're up against each other do
you what did you do and how did you say
okay here's how we handle this or did
you even talk about my big break we
hugged it out like as soon as I found
out that he got nominated and we saw
each other the next day at work we just
hugged it was all love man like you know
like testimony to Fogelman that he can
create a show that has two male
characters that don't have intersecting
storylines both get this level of
recognition you know it's the writing
that we got six actors from our show
nominated from art for an Emmy and we
didn't get any recognition for our
writers the writers do a whole lot we i
but the writers do a whole lot to get a
step I just asked Brian Tyree Henry if
he come back he said Ricky still there
Ricky's a medic maybe Keith come back
feeling me let it be you officially
ended ideas the cover band what here's
part of this is us universe and we
anticipate knock on something seen them
again this year
okay so good happen yes most that Justin
said you guys have all watched the first
three episodes that is correct not
they're not complete did we but do we
find out what happened to Jack
howdy that you find out something we
find out something let me tell you this
lady this is the best part so when we
watch the three episodes the scene that
gives you the most information regarding
Jack's demise has not been shot yet so
it's something that we shot just this
week oh come on so that there will be no
leaks and no spoilers and it ain't gonna
happen from the brother man
[Music]
you